is there a silent majority
oh let's talk about it ladies and
gentlemen the moment you've all been
waiting for
the cato institute has this article poll
62 percent of americans say they have
political views they're afraid
afraid to share 50 of strong liberals
support firing trump donors 36 of strong
conservatives support firing biden
donors
32 are worried about missing out on job
opportunities because of their political
opinions
right away where does the 62 come from
then out of those numbers
it doesn't it's everybody have political
views they're afraid to share
these these are what i've been saying
for a long time now
these numbers are among liberals so like
50 of the liberals
okay would fire someone for being a
trump supporter well so
so not in like the the classic liberal
sense because technically we're all
liberals like
america is a liberal com country you
know
you're talking about like the classical
liberalism okay
yeah so like the crazy left like exactly
okay
well so they're probably using strong
liberal in the in the modern sense
which means leftist right right i really
can't stand it i agree
i agree with you it's not the same thing
it's like they're trying to make
being liberal a negative thing and
that's that couldn't be further from the
truth
there's some interesting stuff here
let's read this go ahead and it sounds
like we may have located
the silent majority hmm a new i mean
literally it says
they're scared to share their opinions
62 percent
look at this 62 agree the political
climate these days prevents me from
saying things i believe because others
might find them offensive
oh uh is it offensive to say you support
black lives matter
nope every brand corporation does it so
i will tell you this
well actually yes it does to specific
people
right and they've made it very clear
that it's offensive to them if
major corporations and brands have no
problem whatsoever
supporting progressive causes they
believe that
it's safe to share true that says to me
if these people are scared to say things
it's not what pepsi said because pepsi
said it right it's mainstream and
popular and what's the what's the
statistic on americans that approve of
all lives matter versus
black lives matter 58 view all lives
matter as positive
and and like 46 to 40 or whatever yeah
view black guys matter as positive right
so there's a lot of overlap but there's
more americans who view all lives matter
positively and this is according to the
economist
and yougov i believe yeah let's read
this they say a new cato national survey
finds that self uh
that self-censorship is on the rise
nearly two-thirds
62 percent of americans say their
political climate these days prevents
them from saying things they believe
because others might find them offensive
the share of americans who self-censor
has risen
several points since 2017 when 58
of americans agreed with this statement
these fears cross partisan lines
majorities of democrats 52 percent
independence 59
and republican 77 all agree they have
political opinions they're afraid to
share
yeah and how many of them are going to
say i'm satisfied with this existence or
they're going to say
give me the guy who made fun of rosie
o'donnell on stage
you ever seen that video from trump yeah
yeah where is where megan kelly is like
what did he say you called women fat
pigs he goes only rosie o'donnell
and then everyone starts cheering and
laughing yeah he's a funny guy
man liberals are divided on political
expression strong liberals stand out
however
as the only political group who feel
they can express themselves
nearly six in ten fifty eight percent of
staunch liberals feel they can say what
they believe
that's exactly what i was saying yeah hi
hello right here
how what's reaching that's me however
centrist liberals feel differently
a slim majority 52 of liberals feel they
have to self-censor
as do 64 of moderates 77 percent of
conservatives
this demonstrates that political
expression is an issue that divides the
democratic coalition
between centrist democrats and their
left flank and thus
the silent majority confirmed yeah
77 of conservatives aren't speaking up
at all
this means i'm talking strong liberals
feel the majority they can say whatever
they can say for whatever they want
yeah yeah because their politics are
mainstream in brands and media so wait
strong lip
liberals would be like the leftists okay
so i am not a leftist liberal
right in any sense so look i am a
classic liberal
think about what this means if the if
there's a majority of moderates
centrist liberals and conservatives who
feel they can't say certain opinions
those opinions do not exist in the
political conversation and that
that shows though that there are people
on the left
that probably are voting for trump this
shows that the majority of the country
isn't saying what they really think yep
they're not speaking up
they're silent that explains and they're
the majority
boom wait let me get my full camera hold
on
boom smash that like button oh that felt
so good i feel vindicated right now
i need some smashes but i had to get
that off my chest
does that mean they'll vote for trump it
doesn't matter they exist
they do they exist and it's proof they
exist and it this
proves people aren't we
talked about this earlier so you can you
can go out and be like i'm voting for
biden
and you might get some weird looks but
that's the extent of it no no no no
even if if you walked into a group of
secret trump supporters yeah and went
i'm voting for biden they'd go
yeah you're here yeah okay liar cool
good for you
so if you can publicly say you're voting
for biden and everyone cheers yep then
trump supporters are going to be lying
about who they're voting for
exactly so this is hello the biggest and
most important point in the polling
is there's two there's two things one i
think it was the new york times that
found
telephone poles tend to over represent
biden support
of course and because when a journalist
calls you and says
hi i'm a journalist from the new york
times
who are you voting for you go i'm not
telling this guy he's gonna dox me he's
gonna he's gonna
he sounded creepy
[Laughter]
channeling a little bite in there a
little bit oh man i gotta say though i
gotta look fat uh here's the deal well
that feels good
having like an actual like proof
of what i've been saying of what i
believe this is what this is most
americans
it is like perfect like america being
strong they
they want america to be so so unless
they want the job what do you what
period what were those things that nancy
pelosi was wearing kente cloth is that
yeah
so what do you think regular americans
are thinking when they see the democrats
drop to their knees wearing kente claws
they're gonna be like
what is happening we don't like that
yeah listen look at this poll right here
staunch liberals stand out as the only
group who feels they can share their
political opinions
agree or disagree the political climate
these days prevents me from saying
things i believe because others might
find them offensive
strong liberal is the only faction that
disagrees with that statement
that means what they say is more so
safe to say yep and most other people
are afraid to say what they believe
conservatives and strong conservatives i
can't do it
what that means is everybody is lying
because no one feels like it's safe to
say these things
so i mean look when adam did his his bit
where he's like you know you said you're
going to vote for trump yep
it goes on facebook 2.4 million views
and facebook
deleted it yep now what would happen if
you were like you got to vote for biden
man biden's the the way the truth
you know he's the put it at the top of
the algorithm yep you get a lot fewer
views but you'd be at the top of the
algorithm people wouldn't be sharing it
but they would not ban you yep same
thing with twitter man
and i was warning about this like a long
time ago what happens when they start
censoring and all this stuff
they have they have whipped themselves
into a paranoid delusional state that
they believe is reality
that's true they're they're eating their
own refuse believing it's true
but will this translate into a victory
for trump we don't know
i mean what scares me is they keep
saying like well
trump's trump's you know election fraud
like he's gonna he's gonna try to do all
this stuff and i'm like
no everyone's gonna vote for him you're
you're you're afraid
you're afraid democrats they are and
they should be because
the majority of americans are going to
vote for trump
period this is uh you know you know what
i'm going to say if you haven't
subscribe notification bell and i'll
tell you why because this next paragraph
explains everything oh boy
i i we started this show and i was
thinking like we'll probably have some
decent growth the show's been
exploding we're getting a hundred
thousand subscribers per month on
average in the past couple months it's
nuts
i want that i want that doubled
now you guys are amazing it's amazing
but check it out check it out enough for
adam there's a very good reason why
and they've nailed it look at this okay
in 2017
most centrist liberals felt confident
they could express their views at 54
however today slightly less than half 48
percent feel the same
the share who feel they cannot be open
increased seven
points from 45 to 2017 to 52
today in fact there have been shifts
across the board
where most people among all political
groups feel they're walking on
eggshells boom wow there are
conservative shows that have always been
conservative
and they tell you conservatives things
and conservatives like that but there
are very few shows where there are like
centrist moderate center left or center
right opinions
that like regular people who are like
i'm not very strong politically here's
how i think
but no one says it because you're either
safe on the conservative side where you
know you have your conservative allies
or the progressives who think everyone's
on their side and they're right so we
start doing things where we're like
i'm saying you know i guess i'll end up
voting for trump i'm leaning that
direction he's not that bad
you're saying i'm not gonna vote for him
but this is this is a show
with a hippie skateboarding pro
skateboarder rockstar guy who like first
started reading about trump and also was
like whoa i'm gonna vote for this guy
whoa his policies are actually legit
he's he's actually pretty great i'm not
saying he's he's not that bad i'm saying
i actually
really like him as a president and and
so this is exactly what i'm saying
with so many people scared to say the
kind of things you're saying
you know i was talking to somebody who's
like a prominent hollywood figure
and you'd be surprised i've mentioned
this before there are a ton especially
after doing rogan
i got hit by a ton of like hollywood la
types
who are secretly conservative and not
necessarily conservative but like
politically homeless liberals yeah so
intellectual dark web is probably an
easy way to explain what kind of views
these people have
and they're saying things like they
either did vote for trump they're going
to vote for trump but they know their
careers and lives will be destroyed if
they say anything
so where do they go when they themselves
are like
hipster skateboarding vegans they don't
agree with conservatives
and so i was talking to this hollywood
dude and he was like listen man you got
to understand
like when i turn on you know youtube and
i see a dude wearing like a beanie and a
hoodie or whatever
and you're like a skateboarder a
musician who's like you
what what we need to understand is like
finally it feels like
i get it because it's it's really funny
when the far left tries to claim that i
or we are like far right or conservative
or whatever yeah because you ask a
conservative and they're like no of
course not those guys are liberals
you know you look at dave ruben you look
at ben shapiro it's like the perfect
example it's like
clearly they're at odds with tons of
each other's well while dave has moved
more to the right
you get the point when you when you look
at traditional conservatives you see
like go to cpec everyone's wearing a
suit
they're dressed up they're not a beanie
wearing skateboarder
yeah so all of a sudden now you know
we're having conversations from a very
centrist liberal perspective
that didn't exist before i mean i'm i
don't claim to be a republican now
you know i i never really claimed to be
a democrat i would have
i probably would have answered if
someone asked me are you a republican or
democrat i probably would have said
democrat
in the past but then again default i had
no idea what
anything politics like this whole year
has just been me
like learning the political landscape so
now that i understand it
i'm not a republican or democrat i'm an
american
period well trump is not
a hardcore conservative i know even vox
the progressive outlet said he was a
moderate
they try to claim he's far right he's
fringe he's all these awful things and
it's like
his policies really did overlap a lot
with this this is what people need to
realize
one of donald trump's successes was that
his policies did
overlap with democrats 10 years ago
it made it very difficult for them to
find a position
because when when trump comes out and
says we're going to secure our borders
we're going to deal with immigration
illegal immigration well most people are
like that sounds great democrats what do
you have to offer
if they came out and said we completely
agree but we're slightly weaker than
trump
yeah they'd be like uh no no thanks wait
hold on hold on i got something
build back better they'll build back
better build build back better we gotta
build back better like lying dog face
pony soldier listen biden just say make
america great again that's
that's what you want to say man like
come on really yeah
build back better what does that even
mean did you see
means make america great again that's
what you're trying to that's what you
want
get out of here it's like he's a he's a
dollar store version of trump right
he wants to be like trump actually
actually that's unfair it's not even
unfair he's like uh he's in the dumpster
of the dollar store
it's like it's it's no no no no you know
what biden is
biden is like when you see those memes
of stolen ip from from china
yeah where it's like spider-man with
wolverine claws it says star wars on it
that's biden plagiarism confusing makes
no sense
you know it's funny it makes you laugh
so we have his face to make fun of
that's got all sorts of layers to it
yeah i really like that
that was good that's multi-layers but
you've seen those things i love they
have oh yeah you're like star wars and
it's spiderman with wolverine claws
you're like friend but worse
yeah right listen listen not to
recognize listen here fat
you go to a dollar store they got your
essentials man yeah yeah they got a
little bit of everything
it's not like walgreens no
but i can't stand it though because
that's part part of the issue of what we
do as americans
i mean i was i'll just talk about myself
you know i was used to just going to buy
the product that i need
oh it broke go buy a new product oh it
broke go buy a new product and that is
across the board what we need to get rid
of what happened to the days where we
fix everything
we have our one cups we have you know
that we have the things that we know
we can fix and keep them forever and
their quality amer
that's what america made is to me build
back better
build back better check this out check
this out we got more data
look at this oh man would you support or
oppose
firing a business executive from their
job if it became known they privately
donated money to
31 among all polled said
they would support firing a trump donor
22 percent
would support firing a biden donor
conservatives
uh would not wan only 36 percent would
say fire a biden donor
but 50 of strong liberals would fire a
trump donor you that means
yeah if if orange isn't bad
it's very very clear tedious 31 of all
people
think you should be fired for donating
to trump you better not say you're
voting
you don't you donated to trump yep you
better shut up now
22 percent would uh among all people
would fire someone for
uh uh donating to biden so there's
probably a lot of people aren't going to
talk too much about that either
but still too partisan it's strong
liberals who control cultural
institutions
absolutely and and half of them will
fire you if they find out
strong conservatives they ain't running
disney and
and gillette or unilever or whatever no
they're not doing it
so what are you really worried about and
not only that are strong conservatives
going to make phone calls
they're not they're going to say well
that guy's a you know
dumb is a box of rocks yeah whatever
anyway what are you guys doing later a
liberal's going to be like
call him now get everybody on the email
list let's show up to his house with
bricks
oh seriously yeah it's frightening
strong liberal what a strong liberal i
mean that's ridiculous
32 worry their political views could
harm their employment
they say nearly a third of employed
americans say they personally are
worried about missing out on career
opportunities or losing their job if
their political opinions became known
these results are particularly notable
given that the most personal can uh that
most personal campaign contributions to
political candidates
are public knowledge and can easily be
found online
that means trump's donations would be
substantially higher
if canceled culture wasn't a thing and
that might be the point
interesting how many text messages i get
from progressives because i donated to
andrew yang
it's annoying it's really annoying
really like non-stop dude
and like um you got i'm in i'm running
for you know arkansas and i'm like
no no no no get out of here get out of
here and so it was really funny
i got some progressive texted me and i'm
very polite
um they said something like uh hey you
know
we see that you're a fan of yang we're
running he's endorsed us would you
consider
contributing i'd say i no i appreciate
you know you're reaching out
best of luck please don't contact me in
the future they message me again
and they're like hey it's a different
name now with the same number like we
we're we're hoping to get some donations
for our candidate and i'm like i asked
you last time to stop
you know texting me i'm not going to
donate and they done it again and i
responded the last time with
if you text me one more time i'm going
to donate to your opponent and that and
that was the end of it
yeah yeah and they were like please
don't do that we'll stop i'm
so sorry go ahead hold on yeah give me
one sec this is something that carlin
borisenko does when people give her
trouble on twitter
she tells them she tells them a friend
she's like you're giving me a hard time
please stop
and then if they continue she says i'm
going to donate 25
every time you insult me to donald trump
and she does and she has a lady for whom
she has donated 150 dollars so far
and she won't mute and she's like we're
doing this
really good idea do you remember when i
got here and i was getting those text
messages from the bernie guys from
bernie
oh yeah that's right so i i donated you
were getting bernie sanders for 2016.
look at this guy's all about that
this bernie guy i liked him in 2016. me
too i didn't like him this
this go around listen in in in bernie's
original campaign he was like no open
borders
that's a koch brothers proposal right
here here unions
strong working class you know support
okay i hear you yeah now what is he
saying
open borders decriminalize border
crossings whoa whoa whoa whoa give them
all health care
like what what give them give the people
coming up
right off the bat give them health care
wait no
i i don't agree with you longer i did a
longer breakdown of bernie's positions
yeah how he like
flipped on a bunch of issues and now it
doesn't seem to make sense anymore
but notably i remember the big change
was when he said white people didn't
know it was like to be poor
yeah but go ahead tell me tell me that
story well no so they started hitting me
up and i'm like
all right please please stop i i don't i
don't support bernie anymore
i'm not i'm not having this and then
just like you said it's
it you know three days later another
person hey it's
mike with the bernie campaign or
something and
and i was like tim like look at this you
were like oh man
ask them about uh i don't remember the
millionaires or the billions of like ask
him why he stopped saying millionaires
and just saying billionaires
we we actually had fun we him and i
basically just trolled
trolled these people for a little while
and then finally i was like look i i've
had enough of this
don't don't hit me up again i always do
this because people don't believe me
so i pulled it up while you were talking
oh politifact ding
sanders for saying white people don't
know poverty
that was huge to me i was like whoa
bernie dude
yeah that does not sound like you man
all of a sudden he embraced this
weird insanity so yeah
they've uh do they have the link to uh
wait wait hold on oh this is this is
great there he's working now with biden
right yeah
on a unity platform hold on wait but
didn't biden say poor peop
poor kids are just as smart as white
kids yeah that's what he said
that's that's the problem man so maybe
maybe it was my naivety
oh man maybe maybe listen maybe i was
just naive they're a parent
and when i thought bernie was great it
was because to be honest
i i was following a lot of his old
speeches a lot of the memes a lot of
the things my friends were sharing and i
wasn't actually digging in i was just
looking at bernie on the surface
and i was happy i was like this guy
sounds like he's consistent
and it sounds like we have someone who
actually cares and then give in the
chance
in a split second he was like i'll take
the money
yep just pay me the million dollars i'll
write the book i'll buy another house
and there's bernie yep yeah right spare
me dude the billionaires
the billionaires that's now he's just
talking about the billionaire yeah dude
my favorite thing about bernie is how
you say the millionaires and the
billionaires in this country then he
became a millionaire and he goes
the the billionaires in this country
yeah you can still rag on the
millionaires and be a millionaire you're
not gonna stop yeah but yeah he really
did and he got called out in the media
for it
that we joked about this before that
like bernie used to be on the outside of
the mansion looking through the window
yelling to everyone behind him we're
gonna get in the millionaires and
billionaires
and then finally someone opened the door
and said hey bernie come on in leave
them out there he goes oh okay
and he comes inside and he's inside
sipping one going oh yeah the
the billion is yeah you know that's good
stuff
yeah i think that's right the date he
made a million bucks yeah yep
by how he stopped for first exactly
you're like you can look at when his
campaign removed millionaires yeah and
then be like now let now let's look at
like sales and his tax forms it's like
you know the exact moment he became a
millionaire did you do that i
i'd like to see that data that's pretty
hilarious i'm really curious
yeah you didn't actually do it no i
haven't i'm disappointed
i'm sorry it just occurred to me just
saying i'm just saying i'm just i'm a
little disappointed right it's it's the
year he put out his book and then he
released his tax returns i guess
and he's like a millionaire okay just
barely though but
he's a millionaire i do think i do think
a lot of the criticism towards him for
being a millionaire
is unfair because you can be rich and
advocate for
you know dumb ideas yeah you know just
because you're rich doesn't mean you're
smart you could be self-aware
yeah and and maybe bernie's like wow i
made a million dollars i should give it
away and then he doesn't donate
because like another big scandal is that
he donated a smaller percentage of his
income than like most millionaires do
yeah so i don't blame him man
you know he's not he's not been a
particularly wealthy guy most of his
life
he's old he's very old and finally now
he made a million bucks
he must have been like we can finally
have that summer home we've always
dreamed of
you know it's right i feel i feel for
him you know it's really interesting to
me how
a cent i just looked it up a senator
makes under 200 000 a year and they're
all millionaires
how do they all become millionaires
they're millionaires before
that's not necessarily true well was
bernie a millionaire before
that's true we were just talking about
it you ran for president how are you
going to
solve that no no no no no it's not
spinning it it's that a lot of them are
only able to win because they're
millionaires
because they've had long careers they're
high-ranking individuals they have
connections
okay and they can fundraise off other
very wealthy people for political action
committees and stuff like that
okay so that but but a lot of congress
is really poor
the funny thing about congress people
don't seem to understand is that they
get 174
000 a year which that's a lot of money
yeah but they have to maintain
a living residence in their home
districts and in dc
so there's actually a story about a lot
of them who sleep in their congressional
offices
and they're not they're not supposed to
do it but what are you gonna do you
can't you know
you can't they can close their office
you can't come in i guess they shower
there or something but i gotta be honest
man if i was in congress
i'd absolutely do that yeah i'm not
gonna waste money what do i look like
i guess when you grow up frugal and poor
you're like no no no i don't need an
infinity pool like you you have to be
some kind of
lunatic you know some kind of deranged
psychopath to get elected to congress
and then go to like some luxury
apartment building with an infinity pool
and like a whole foods in the lobby
you know you know what i mean yeah i
know exactly that kind of insane person
would do that
and then demand a raise yeah are you
talking about a certain somebody right
now
i i don't i don't know what you mean
yeah i don't know i don't know what you
mean
yes i'm talking about alexandria
ocasio-cortez okay i thought so
she she's she said that they should pay
congress more
i actually agree okay they should
however
it's like you gotta you got apparently
there's like an infinity pool
on a roof i don't know if that's true
whatever but she's in like very nice dc
apartments and there's like a whole
foods apparently
you know honestly i don't track her
living circumstance but i know that
michelle cruz cabrera who was
challenging her in the primary like
talked about this all the time yeah
so look if you want to ask for a raise
for congress there are reasons to do
this we want to disincentivize
corruption
we want to make sure that people who get
in are incentivized to do
work successfully for the people doesn't
necessarily mean you give a million
dollars and maybe a raise doesn't make
sense but it's an argument for
potentially some kind of pay structure
that and a limit like like andrew yang
said
something like pay them millions of
dollars but then they're no longer
eligible for private income
okay so it's like as soon as you enter
this that way you can't be
bribed yeah like to leave will give you
a job and you can't become lobbyists you
know there is something about aoc that i
do like
it is kind of what i was talking about
earlier useful exuberance
well sure but it's
it's more than that it she is a
celebrity as a senator
congresswoman oh okay right excuse me as
a congresswoman so
but that's kind of what we we need
that's kind of what i was talking about
earlier we got to stop
idolizing movie stars so much and
realize that the people that are
actually making the decisions for our
lives
like we gotta look at them and pay more
attention to them and and
and look at them and and want to be more
like them
like i'm not saying i want people to be
like aoc
but she's proving that there can be a
celebrity status
in what she's doing well so so let me
let me let me build on top of that
i actually i do like aoc as a politician
compared to what the rest of the
democrats have to offer for the most
part okay
because i would rather have an inept
braggart celebrity who
is not part of the crony corrupt class
of
business interests and all that stuff
you know what i mean sounds familiar to
me
right exactly like the president of the
united states of america and i've
made this i've called aoc like a mini
kind of trump
yeah many times i could see that
actually however there are much better
people than aoc in terms of real
populist politicians
like like i i would say uh matt gates
for instance
would be like a more principled version
of aoc aocs
what we need are what we need to do is
we need to get rid of these incumbents
who have built careers off being
politicians they don't actually do
anything yeah
chuck schumer nancy pelosi yeah get him
out of there biden
same thing right they're all the same
they're not making any help they're not
helping anybody but themselves
aoc in my opinion is one of the best
democrats
simply because she came like she's not a
part of the
of the corrupt dc establishment and
however and that's where it stops
exactly and now and now i'll say she is
she is far from my favorite politician
period and she has a whole list of
problems
yeah ineptitudes listen but i'll tell
you what men i'd rather have someone
who's really dumb
than someone who's really corrupt yeah
now i'm not saying i'd choose either of
them if i had a choice of somebody else
and people people then this is the thing
people like to say trump is dumb and
it's like they couldn't be further
from the truth that could be further
from the truth not at all he is he is a
smart cookie man he knows what he's
doing
he may not be the smartest person in the
world you can argue whether or not 4d
chess is a real thing
but i i get so annoyed when i talk to
people and they're like man that guy's
so dumb and i'm like if you think he's
dumb
and he became president then what does
that mean about you like what did it say
about you you know i mean
that's true listen man if the
billionaire philandering
uh uh president tv show host reality
uh real estate mogul is dumb and you
working at starbucks
man come on yeah i said i said to
someone i was like well you know he has
a
degree in economics right and they say
and they tried to
argue with me that he didn't and i was
like
oh okay you know he no he actually does
you can look up
no no he does not no i'm sorry no you're
wrong
he didn't go to school like what do you
mean like he he did he went to
he went he got it from the university of
pennsylvania like i know it i saw the
like what are you talking about look it
up yourself
no i don't have to look it up but to be
fair aoc also has a degree in economics
okay all makes sense but
that trump was a billionaire aoc was a
bartender
no no no i'm absolutely not dragging aoc
for being a bartender i hate that
when people are like go back to serving
bars blah blah blah i'm like that's
i love the fact that she was a bartender
this is america man yeah it's proving
that we
anybody any one person with the right
ideas can make it into
into office and make a difference that's
what i want to start seeing
i want to see all the all of the crony
republicans and democrats
fired yep there are right now more
principled republicans in my opinion
than democrats
but and it's because the democratic
party is like it's it's led by lunacy
pandering to extremists who don't
actually know what they're talking about
and regular people are like i don't want
to be involved in that anymore that's a
good point so now you're probably going
to see
you're probably going to see a lot of
centrist liberals not all of them but
many of them
probably voting for republican because
it's a safer and more
stable bet right but i'll tell you what
i will take
more aocs over nancy pelosi's
if if nancy nancy pelosi is is just
awful and i've actually said had nice
words about her in the past about their
fee with aoc but at this point
i'm like that was a mistake aoc is a lot
of things
and not and smart is not one of them
yeah in a lot of ways but you know i
will give her credit for the successes
she's had
i don't think all of her ideas are bad
i've actually when she first won the
primary i went through her her campaign
positions i agree with many of them
prison reform things like that but she's
become too much of a celebrity who cares
more about the buzz words
than about legitimate functioning policy
she's done dumb things like the green
new deal i don't like any of that
but i would rather have a stupid person
who believes in their cause
than a corrupt person who's trying to
steal money from the coffers
when i look to the establishment
democrats i see people who just want me
to give them my money they're people who
are like if i get elected
i'm rich and successful and i can
control everything i see people like aoc
and she's in my opinion not very bright
that's just my opinion people can
disagree
but at least she's not part of whatever
that weird gross
swamp monster machinas let me ask you a
question do you
what do you think about term limits i
i'm 50 50. i used to say yes but then
someone made a really good point in the
super chat in one episode when they said
what if you have a rand paul a really
good or a ron paul a really
principled you know politician that you
want to be there for you
why should they not be able to run
anymore well i i i can answer that
question
it's those types of like if we actually
start looking at at these
representatives as our idols and like
wanting to be there
that that one person that rand paul is
going to show
what a good senator is what a good
politician is
and we're going to have more of those
type of people trying to get into
politics
and it's going to continue with the
generations that follow
you know there comes a point where it
feels like the older generation loses
touch with the younger generation
and there needs to be a gap there
instead right now it's like all these
people have been there for so long so
they're
you know the the newer generation aren't
even getting into politics anymore
because
everybody wants to be youtubers
everybody wants to be famous
everyone wants to be a an actor or a
musician and it's like
okay well well we we we don't want vapid
look
like i'm i'm i'm saying i'd rather have
aoc over pelosi but i'd rather have a
million other people over aoc
okay i'm just saying like i think the
establishment dems are the bottom of the
barrel
but i i'm not going to vote or support
aoc i'm just saying it's like
so we don't want vapid celebrity mon
like influencers to become politicians
sure
yeah of course then they're more
concerned about how they look on
instagram or on c-span than they do
about actually passing bills
okay but we do need passionate populist
people who care about
principle and so we have a handful of
them yeah we need a lot more
we do i absolutely agree that's that's
why i'm seeing a lot of younger
younger people running for for congress
you know people my age
that are making differences look man
even even far leftists
they're they're taking charge man a lot
of the far a lot of younger far leftists
are challenging establishment older
uh democrats yeah that's why i mean and
but i i mean we just did this article
that people are even afraid
to to tell people what their political
views are
if they're right-leaning if they're
conservative so if it's not okay
even even centrists even centrists
exactly so if you're not even
even able to talk about your political
views if you're
if you're steering towards on the
conservative side of things then
well then of course the the leftists are
going to be riding in and taking over
so we have to have more conversations
and let it be okay
and have people that are more on the
right side coming up and and becoming
younger senators and representatives
then section 230 reform
that's that's one thing we need to do
absolutely 100
the reason why this liberal strong
liberal bias exists where they can say
whatever they want
it's it's it's so obvious man let me
show you this data point real quick and
then we'll jump over to super chats
when you see this graph i'll tell you
exactly why this
is strong liberals disagree they can say
what they want
everyone else agrees they can't why
these people will be banned from twitter
instantly
these people
the system thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast we do
the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next
episode
you